la casse
mort par k o dix jours après un combat
contesté qui l'avait plongé dans le coma
le jeune boxeur david qui au et mort à
lyon la préparation du second tour des
municipales les verts maintiendront leur
propre liste
dans la plupart des plages chili le
président finaux chez va-t-il rester au
pouvoir malgré son échec au référendum
sur portrait ce sport et son interview
demain dans ce journal favori pour les
oscars dustin hoffman parle de son
dernier rôle dans red man film sort
demain en france
voilà monsieur ben soit la boxe mérite
t'elle la mort le noble art selon ce
qu'ils apprécient ça comme au tilt de
combat mal équilibré organisé pour
distraire les salles plutôt que pour
respecter ces règles
david ciot en est mort il avait 22 ans
il ya dix jours il avait affronté à lyon
un boxeur américain qui l'avait frappé à
la face jusqu'au coma il serait le 392e
boxer à mourir pour le sport jean ma
mère david ciot ne connaîtra donc jamais
le haut de la fiche ni celui du showbiz
dont il rêvait ni celui de la boxe
milieu dans lequel son étoile pourtant
commencé à briller tout s'est arrêté le
soir du 4 mars contre l'américain ali il
meurt après dix jours d'un coma profond
après 18 combat la boxe synonyme de rêve
est devenu comme pour beaucoup de ses
compatriotes synonyme de
et de détresse samuel mec arrivé en
france en 76 au lendemain des jeux
olympiques rêve treize ans plus tard
après 36 combats souvenirs il a tout
perdu sa petite fille de 8 ans placé à
la dass et pour 200 francs il a pris des
coups comme sparring partners sont des
esclaves delà de la boxe et cela on a
besoin d'eux vont impulser des pulsions
de bus trop de la boxe pour bon nombre
d'entre eux la boxe est une impasse
enfin certains comme simon après 19
combats victorieux mais un an à dormir
au coin du ring ont préféré abandonner
pour éviter la clochardisation
ça c'est bien je suis papa m'a jamais
jamais compris la ville je crois que je
vais t'emmener les coûts beaucoup
d'autres comme le malien moussa sangaré
n'arrive pas à combattre
arrivé en france en 83 humains disputé
que 17 combats mais il fait peur
remplaçant au pied levé le 14 février 87
de l'écossé holmes
il écrase le poids coq fabrice bénichou
depuis bénichou est devenu champion du
monde des super coq
moussa a remporté trois autres victoires
en trois combats mais il ne disputera
jamais un titre mondial
ce qu'ils demandent boxer à sa juste
valeur et pratiquer un sport que ni vous
ni moi ne sommes prêts à comprendre
j'élabore on
m
le président de la fédération française
de boxe s'est déclaré ce soir consterné
pour des victimes et pour la boxe ils
sont donc morts tous les trois morts au
nom de dieu selon les deux frères qui
reproche est à leurs soeurs ses
fréquentations amoureuses
le drame a eu lieu hier après midi au
soleil au lycée de suresnes un étudiant
marocain de 25 ans se suicidait vous
savez après avoir abattu sa demi soeur
et son demi-frère des jeunes gens comme
il faut bien intégrer
selon leurs proches qui ont dit leur
consternation and gas burgi qu'at-il
bien pu se passer dans la tête de sa
mire du leem 24 ans étudiant en sciences
politiques à la faculté d'orsay
le jeune marocain s'était confié à son
professeur un homme aujourd'hui
bouleversé n'est pas du tout le
comportement est bien mais s'il m'avait
expliqué que des problèmes de famille il
avait été obligé de travailler parce
qu'il a été mis à la porte de chez lui
13 allez remarquer qu'il était très
engagé j'y joue pas du tout pas du tout
pas du tout simplement il était assez
renfermé mais samir et son frère ont
expliqué leur geste en invoquant elles
là et cela dans des lettres retrouvées
hier sur leur corps l'intégrisme
religieux est il pour autant la seule
clé de cette tragédie
au delà du déshonneur face à une soeur
qui fréquentent un non musulman
il y a peut être un drame familial
simplement de la jalousie
ilham vive est ici à la cité
universitaire de nanterre depuis
quelques semaines depuis que sa mère les
avait chassés elle et ses deux frères
ilham avait une liaison avec un français
un homme de 42 ans
cette liaison elle avait récemment avoué
à ses frères il avait tout fait pour la
dissuader mais la jeune fille avait
menacé d'abandonner ses études de rompre
avec sa famille des parents qui ce soir
cachent leur désespoir chez eux seuls
une amie a accepté de nous répondre à
des prix bien mérité tellement épuisée
et une craie travail il a toujours été
très bonne
elle est vraiment très sérieux défis
vraiment très sérieuse et les garçons
c'est pareil la ligne et je ne les ai
pas vraiment il était vraiment et je
vous en prie c'est vous faites votre
travail
aramis ici le recteur de l'institut
musulman de la grande mosquée de paris
cheikh abbas récuse toute civilisation
entre ce meurtre familial et les lois de
l'islam
il met en cause d'ignorance moins on est
éduqué plus on est extrémiste et
intolérant dit il pourtant ce drame met
en évidence de façon exacerbée les
difficultés les tensions les recoins
obscurs de l'assimilation dans une autre
culture ou en particulier la sexualité
se vit différemment
dominique terre 7 ans pendant sept ans
où rien n'a pas vu son père il refusé de
la rencontrer parce qu'elle fréquentait
un français un non musulman ou rien et
marocaines sa famille vit en france
depuis plus de 25 ans lorsqu'elle s'est
mariée tout est rentré dans l'ordre
puisque s'était convertie je ne leur ai
rien dit au départ j'ai posé ça comme un
fait accompli
bon je suivais avec quelqu'un mon père
lui voulait jamais en entendre parler et
ça fait seulement que trois ans qui
commence à avoir des contacts avec lui
mais
c'est pas que je vous ai pas en parler
c'est parce que le dialogue se fait pas
en général avec les pères dans les
familles maghrébines
traditionnellement le dialogue se fait
avec la mer et c'est la mère qui est
plutôt porte parole entre le père et les
enfants et surtout les filles
non moi je me pose problème du pays
jusqu'à maintenant moi je voulais bien
pour ma fille il est bien pour moi -
qu'est-ce que je voulais je voulais me
fait qu'il soit bien été moi aussi sûr
je suis bien même situation pour mounia
qui vivait avec frédéric sont amis
depuis six ans ils se sont mariés il ya
trois ans frédéric a dû lui aussi se
convertir pour être accepté chez ses
beaux parents
il ne pouvait me recevoir que si j'étais
mariée avec un musulman donc pour eux ça
ne se poser par soit mon mari devenait
jugement soit ne recevez plus en france
15 à 17 milles mariages mixtes sont
célébrés par an dans la plupart des cas
les hommes français adoptent la religion
musulmane de leurs épouses qui s'y
opposent leurs femmes leurs enfants
n'ont aucun droit sorti de fromentin
l'étranger dans un pays étranger
bon c'est tout à fait normal c'est à
dire la seule chose qu'on a en face
c'est la ccl là c'est la religion parce
que moi je connais par exemple le pas
mal d'ouvriers où j'avais fait des
enquêtes bons jeux d'essai des ouvriers
qui sont très heureux du genre en france
parce que nous les maghrébins on est
quand même attaché à la france quelque
part qu'en langue on veut pas parce que
les français sont nos amis mais on a
quand même notre religion la religion
l'unique rempart d'une société immigrés
parfois perdu égaré un rempart qui dans
la plupart des cas prône d'abord la
tolérance je suis venu vous dire que je
ne vous laisse pas tomber
je crois que vous retrouverez vos
enfants c'est en ces termes que le
président mitterrand a réconforté cet
après-midi à l'aéroport d'orly quatre
jeunes femmes qui font depuis quinze
jours la grève de la faim pour récupérer
leur en forme ne peux disait par leur
père algérien
le chef de l'état accompagné pour cette
visite surprise d'un homme georgina
dufoix a précisé que le président chadli
veiller au règlement de ce douloureux
problème
une demi heure pour soutenir le candidat
socialiste michel rocard n'est pas resté
longtemps dans le 20e arrondissement de
paris qui fera l'objet dimanche prochain
d'une lutte serrée entre le rpr et le ps
n'est arbitré par jean marie le pen le
premier ministre que vous voyez là
faisant paisiblement le tour des
commerçants du quartier le premier
ministre a été conspué ensuite par une
quinzaine d'enseignants et il est
reparti plus vite que prévu
effervescence en tout cas dans les états
majors politiques des plus petites aux
plus grandes communes les listes pour le
second tour doivent en effet être
déposées avant minuit ce soir et les
verts n'aiment pas qu'on leur fasse la
cour de manière politicienne c'est ce
qu'ils disent et c'est pourtant le cas
dans plusieurs municipalités les
écologistes après leurs bons résultats
dès dimanche dernier ont fait l'objet de
toutes sortes d'empressement
mais dans la plupart des cas ils
maintiendront leur propre liste
jean-michel merkel l'histoire ne dit pas
si la cigogne laurent saura gré mais les
écologistes ont voulu faire de
strasbourg le symbole de leur volonté
d'autonomie en refusant la fusion avec
les socialistes ni groupe écologiste
autonome au sein du conseil municipal
ça a été refusé ce qui a été aussi
refusé c'est qu'on puisse encore
discuter leurs programmes vous voulez
qu'on s'engage sur leur charte pour
strasbourg
courtisé à gauche et à droite les verts
ont préféré globalement se maintenir
pour le second tour c'est vrai dans la
plupart des 16 villes de plus de 30
mille habitants où il avait dépassé les
10% au premier tour
mulhouse quimper lorient poitiers
nanterre limoges ainsi qu'à paris dans
le 14e arrondissement
seule exception notable talence où ils
ont accepté la fusion avec la liste de
la socialiste catherine lalumière qui
leur offre six élus et lille où pierre
mauroy leur garantit cette place dont 5
éligibles enfin dans les villes où les
verts n'étaient pas en position de se
maintenir
ils ont généralement choisi de se
retirer sans consigne de vote à cas
particuliers où l'arbitrage des verts
risquent de compliquer le duel entre la
droite et la gauche
le cas de quimper sur place henry
deux des trois candidats toujours en
lice
l'un est écologiste l'autre le maire rpr
sortant il ne convergent pas de la pluie
ou du beau temps mais de béton et de
verdure pour alain uguen qui conduit la
liste des verts un seul credo envers et
contre tout se maintenir l'autonomie
nous paraît être la condition nécessaire
pour la survie d'un mouvement politique
indépendant
c'est évident que l'on perd toute
crédibilité si on commence à dire bon
nous on accepte si vous fumez ceci est
pourtant hier soir bernard poignant le
député du finistère tête de liste ps
leur propose un ultime marché pour mieux
savourer encore les banques rue89 des
roses dans l'ouest il est prêt à céder
quelques lopins de terre pour conquérir
demain de plus vastes domaines
j'ai fait deux propositions aux
écologistes pour leur offrir six sièges
de conseiller municipal et deux postes
d'adjoint en cas de victoire leur
intransigeance a été totale et il
souhaite poursuivre
par conséquent je respecte leur choix et
il y aura à quimper trois listes
quant au maire rpr marc bécam il voit sa
cote de popularité s'effriter au fil des
saisons à l'image quelque peu fané du
parti gaulliste de la région je crois
que le vote écologiste est un vote qui
est un appel pour nous un avertissement
un petit peu une sorte de message
elle nous l'avons entendu et j'entends
développer l'action dans le domaine des
quartiers dans le domaine de la qualité
de la vie et aussi le soutien des chats
forme qui doit être accrue et à la vie
associative
ni droite ni gauche c'est donc le
nouveau slogan des écologistes ici à
quimper autre arbitre du second tour le
front national qui a conforté son
emprise dans un certain nombre de
municipalités notamment dans le sud
jean-marie le pen a une nouvelle fois
aujourd'hui plaidé pour l'alliance à
droite en s'en prenant vivement aux
responsables de l'opposition qui on sait
on récuse et dès dimanche soir toute
fusion de listes s'il vous méprise
mépriser les conseils
le président du front national à ses
partisans ce ne sera pas le cas à aix en
provence où le maire sortant udf devrait
signer ce soir un accord avec le front
national à expatrient ce volet
dilemme à droite à la mairie d'aix faire
ou ne pas faire alliance négociations
interminables
tout l'après-midi les aixois ont attendu
la nouvelle en vain à la mairie enfermé
depuis 14h30 le maire udf jean pierre de
peretti 19 8% dimanche et la tête de
liste front national philippe milliau
15% vers 18 heures on croit à l'accord
signé en fait il n'en est rien le sa
permanence philippe bouvet celui-là
faire au téléphone avec ses 19 7%
le candidat rpr veut une grosse part du
gâteau pour faire alliance nous avons
proposé un champion de pertinent de
faire liste commune sur les bases
suivantes 16 élus de notre liste en
position éligible et nous choisissons
nous mêmes ces 16 personnes
les réponses allons nous n'avons pas de
réponse encore il nous a proposé
d'autres chiffres au départ et
actuellement nous sommes donc en pleine
négociation qui peut durer bien sûr un
peu tard dans la nuit
ce soir pourtant il semble que la tête
de liste rpr soit plus hostile que le
maire udf à la présence de candidats
front national sur une éventuelle liste
d'union
ce suspense électoral prendra fin ce
soir toutes les listes doivent être
impérativement déposer à la préfecture
avant minuit ici à aix tous les types
d'accords sont envisageables d'une liste
unique udf rpr front national un simple
accord udf rpr
dans les deux cas le plus difficile sera
d'équilibrer les listes et de faire une
place à toutes les ambitions
courtoisie sérénité et même générosité
comme il s'y est au vainqueur à lyon
michel noir et francisque collomb ont
tenu une conférence de presse commune
tout à l'heure pour annoncer la fusion
de leurs listes pour le second tour
michel noir offert 14 juillet
l'udf dans le prochain conseil municipal
au lieu des 7 ou 8 que leur garantissait
que l'arithmétique électorale sur le
plan humain c'est comme ça que les
choses doivent être faites a précisé le
futur maire de lyon à gauche pierre
mauroy appelle à nouveau à l'union le
premier secrétaire du parti socialiste
répondra demain matin à 7h45 aux
questions de gérard morin aux 4 vérités
les municipales sur un thème de cette
eau si le minitel 36 15 codes civique ou
36 15 codes à 2 vous pouvez plus de 200
mille téléspectateurs n'ont déjà fait
trouver ainsi les résultats qui vous
intéressent
c'est à nouveau la guerre au liban non
pas que ce malheureux pays depuis 13 ans
soit jamais tout à fait sortis mais ce
mardi a été la journée la plus sanglante
depuis cinq ans une trentaine de morts
près de 150 blessés
le général chrétien michel aoun annoncé
ce soir à beyrouth le début de la guerre
de libération contre la syrie dont
l'armée aurait bombardé la région
chrétienne
martine laroche-joubert sinistre litanie
au terme de cette journée de
bombardements à des routes 31 morts et
145 blessés
surpris au volant de la voiture broyée
sous une dizaine d'obus tombés
essentiellement à l'ouest dans le
secteur musulman qui a démarré les
hostilités les deux gouvernements rivaux
du liban
l'impro syria l'autre contre s'accusent
mutuellement
quant à l'annonce du général aoun
hostiles à damas d'entamer le début
d'une guerre de libération contre la
syrie amelio rappelle le sort de ces
libanais en proie à la panique
on peut en douter le bombardement
d'aujourd'hui est le plus violent depuis
quatre ans ce n'est pas le sort du liban
qui préoccupe au premier chef les
dirigeants arabes réunis à ryad en
arabie saoudite
c'est bien davantage la sphère rushdie
que l'iran a fait inscrire à l'ordre du
jour
les saoudiens ne cherche à éviter toute
polémique supplémentaire
envoyé spécial à ryadh pierre serra
sévèrement protégé par une armée
vigilante la richesse ruisselante des
hommes comme la pauvreté endémique des
autres ne sont pas ici au centre des
débats
gimont d'abord leurs rivalités
politiques à gérer et le dogme et son
interprétation fives le même clivage
d'intérêt tous les croyants où qu'ils se
trouvent ce constat un serpent par jour
en direction de la mecque pour prier al
mais aujourd'hui les regardent leurs
représentants réunis à ryad sont tournés
vers téhéran
la république islamique enrayer ici un
fonctionnaire de rang mineurs qui
entendent tenir sa place en défendant en
arabe
la position de son gouvernement dans la
sphère des versets sataniques de salman
rushdie à l'islam c'est l'identité est
reconduite aux communes une mandale bras
de renier ses religions sont tous
d'accord là dessus
théoriquement oui mais quel embarras
pour les autres ils peuvent ni sur un
shérif ni en tout cas faire moins que
l'ayatollah khomeiny et la ressurgit la
rivalité séculaire entre les chiites qui
se veulent tantôt ducks et les sunnites
capable de tolérance même défi à propos
de l'afghanistan l'arabie saoudite a été
la première l'iran attend le jour à
reconnaître le gouvenement tmr des
moudjahidine représenté ici par somistes
de zataz étrangères hekmatyar un sunnite
prénommé c'est un signe calpine coeur de
la religion les faire des versets
sataniques et l'afghanistan sont donc un
problème qui permettent d'apprécier au
mieux de l'extérieur le climat de cette
18ème conférence islamique pour le reste
conflit israélo arabe israël sous le nom
des pastilles n'a été occupé aussi bien
que les communautés
il habite dans le monde eh bien on
s'accordera toujours sur des murs qu'ils
règlent rien mais dans la musique que
satisfait une majorité ce n'est pas un
camouflé c'est une gifle pieter botha le
président de l'afrique du sud
renié par son propre parti dont il avait
abandonné la direction de mois dernier
il est tout simplement sommé de
démissionner éric perrin
pieter botha le président de la
république sud-africaine lâché par son
propre parti
entériné à l'unanimité une résolution du
parti national demande instamment sa
démission et son remplacement à la tête
du pays par frederik de klerk le nouveau
leader des nationalistes bigger boat à
73 ans n'a toujours pas réagi at le
désaveu cinglant
bataille pour une ville djalal abad
après huit jours de combats acharnés les
responsables des deux camps affirment
contrôler cette ville clé située entre
kaboul la capitale et le pakistan où
sont basés les rebelles
plus d'une vingtaine d'hélicoptères
militaires gouvernementaux se sont posés
aujourd'hui à djalalabad
on ignore s'ils ont acheminé des
renforts ou s'ils sont venus préparer
l'évacuation de l'armée régulière
explosion à bord d'un cargo transportant
25 mille tonnes de méthane au large du
japon
l' incendie qui ravage de navires ont
fait les secours d'approcher le bâtiment
les 23 membres d'équipage sont portés
disparus
les sauveteurs tentent de contenir les
émanations de gaz toxiques afin d'éviter
qu'un nuage de pollution n'atteigne les
côtes japonaises
que ce passe-t-il au chili cinq mois
après le plébiscite perdu par le général
pinochet aussi que le gouvernement
militaire qui doit rester en place
jusqu'aux prochaines présidentielles ce
gouvernement propose aux différents
partis de modifier la constitution alors
ouverture vers plus de démocratie ou
manoeuvre au contraire pour permettre en
général pinochet au pouvoir jusqu'à la
fin de l'année de se représenter
c'est la question que nous lui poserons
demain puisqu'il a accepté de nous
accorder
et l'occasion ra une interview à
santiago bernard benyamin et pascal
c'est l'état ont déjà réussi à
l'approcher de près de très près
le général est un sportif et c'est un
lève tôt chaque matin à 6h30
il est déjà dans sa salle de gymnastique
au sous-sol de la très belle maison que
l'armée chilienne a mis à sa disposition
mais ce qui surprend le plus ce n'est
pas tant de le voir en plein exercice
encore quelle 73 ans le général démontre
une belle vigueur
non ce qui surprend le plus lorsqu on le
verra quelques minutes plus tard avec sa
fille prendre son premier café de la
journée c'est la voix c'est qu'elles
cadrent mal avec ce que l'on sait de lui
de ce qu'il a fait et de ce qu'il
représente pour l'heure il n'est qu'un
homme 17 fois grand père attentif aux
propos de sa fille lucia
mais avec une pointe d'amertume
lorsqu'il évoque son échec au référendum
d'octobre dernier
sinon ils politique notoire à crottin
pays comme on appelait
il est 7h30 du matin lorsque le cortège
présidentiel pénètre dans les sous-sols
du palais de la moneda ont lagarde
présente les honneurs militaires au
général pinochet
nous sommes dans la halle gauche du
palais de la moneda
celle qui abrite les bureaux
présidentiels celle qui renferme la
galerie des portraits de tous les
présidents qui se sont succédé à la tête
du chili depuis l'indépendance
ce n'est pas une surprise il manque sur
ce mur blanc le portrait d'un seul
président salvador allende
il était président de la république du
chili de novembre 1970 jusqu'à ce fameux
jour du 11 septembre 1973
15 ans ont passé et la moneda été
reconstruite et pour la première fois le
général pinochet accepte de nous faire
visiter l'endroit où est mort
salvador-allende le tabac qui est
totalement n'y aura jamais plus qu'une
personne va faire à la main tendue donc
une sacrée durantez et ses périodes de
l'once est 7e les intéressent aux excès
sauce est la répression qui a maintenu
pour la qualité et la vision onirique à
tout le monde pour ne pas se présenter
nous perdons site dédié qui est celle de
nos héros loiret à 48,9
m
pro cycling des contestations
présentation test si les cocos les
simples aux pattes rien le communisme
est touchant de l'abattre des réseaux
semences ans un taux moyen net mallard
aux arbres comme des dictatures arabes à
la torture bizarre car city où aucun des
treize la personne humaine
les pires horreurs qu'ils auront gaulle
péter long de septembre et 17 en titre s
libertaire de la vad
in fine général pinochet au nombre et
aux biches habitué à ça dit subban et il
faut bien le reconnaître
quinze ans le coup d'état le général
pinochet a réussi à se constituer une
véritable passe populaire des millions
de chiliens qui lui sont reconnaissants
des progrès accomplis
surtout dans le domaine économique
c'était particulièrement frappant
l'autre jour à puerto montt dans le sud
du pays
un accueil très chaleureux qui pourrait
bien décider le général à se présenter
aux élections présidentielles
même si pour le moment il n'en est pas
question il tenait là une pression de
québec en bière et c est sa cible il ya
nos relations
il ya un an par austère karotsch
personnage plus complexe qu'on ne le
supposait
certes c'était sans compter une certaine
lili marlène qui dans un raccourci
saisissant du temps allait nous renvoyer
à d'autres régimes à un autre général
que lui-même peut faire oublier celui de
1973 la dictature à visage humain ou
bien un ancien dictateur gagné par la
démocratie vous vous rentrez de santiago
bernard benyamin s'était d'abord
j'imagine la question que l'on se pose
au chili et que vous vous posez c'est
vrai que c'est une fois qu'il n'y a rien
de plus difficile dans le cas du chili
que de remettre en cause une image que
l'on a peut être voulu conserver intact
mais qui date de 15 ans aujourd'hui le
chili
effectivement à payer tranche qui a
toutes les allures d'une dictature qui
s'est transformée peu à peu en régime
autoritaire par exemple les partis
politiques ont tous pignon sur rue
aujourd'hui à santiago
le parti communiste est interdite mais
il tient des conférences de presse que
couvre et que diffuse la télévision
nationale chilienne le niveau de vie est
plutôt meilleure que dans le reste de
l'amérique latine et puis sans compter
ce qui s'est passé en octobre dernier
voile un dictateur qui se présente
devant son pays pour lui dire oui oui ou
non voulez vous de moi
jusqu'en 1997 à 57%
on lui répond non et voilà notre
dictateur qui dit bon je suis un peu
déçu mais puisque vous ne voulait plus
de moi bien je m'en irai comme le
prévoit la constitution
en mars 1990 avouer que ça n'est tout de
même pas très banal attention je
n'oublie pas ni les torture ni les
arrestations arbitraires qui se continue
aujourd'hui qui se poursuivent
aujourd'hui ni les horreurs du coup
détail des années qui ont suivi mais il
s'est passé quelque chose au chili qui a
changé la nature du régime et la
personnalité de celui qu'il incarne
je crois que cela s'appelle tout
simplement le temps
oui demain dans ce journal grâce à vous
bernard entretien exclusif avec le
général pinochet sa première interview à
une chaîne étrangère depuis bien
longtemps et quelques échanges qui je
l'espère vous surprendre la république
fera à l'impératrice des funérailles
d'état
ainsi en ont décidé les autorités
autrichiennes al'annonce de la mort
aujourd'hui à 97 ans dans un modeste
auspices suisse de zita de habsbourg
elle n'avait signé que deux ans aux
côtés de son mari sur l'autriche hongrie
de 1916 à 1918 les il est nécessaire dit
on à vienne que l'autriche s'identifie
avec les grandes personnalités de son
histoire le destin de gîte a raconté par
michèle mouton peut elle était la nièce
de sissi l'impératrice zita de augsburg
princesse de bourbon-parme impératrice
elle-même d'autriche et de hongrie
s'était éteinte aujourd'hui dans le
modeste deux pièces d'une maison de
retraite grandeurs et misères de la
dernière impératrice d'europe
sa vie ressemble a étonnamment au siècle
qu'elle fréquenta plein de grandeur de
couronnes mais aussi de violences et de
fureur 20 ans sa beauté accompagna
charles 1er ce furent les années lumière
mais cet époux ne se doutait pas qu'il
était le dernier des habsbourgs gh à
porter une couronne impériale le dernier
après six cent quarante ans
ininterrompus ne vont plus tard ce fut
la guerre l'exil
la mort de charles 1er son époux ita de
habsbourg gh aura attendu 66 ans jour
pour jour avant de le rejoindre
elle est morte aujourd'hui loin des
palais et des cours bisons
les funérailles de l'impératrice zita
auront lieu le 1er avril prochain et
seront télévisées en direct en autriche
dustin hoffman ou l'homme de toutes les
métamorphoses vous allez retrouver
l'acteur américain tout à l'heure dans
tootsie ce film de sydney pollack qui
sera diffusée sur antenne 2 juste après
ce journal dustin hoffman grand favori
pour les oscars qui seront décernés le
29 mars prochain
mais pour un autre rôle bouleversant
rain man un film qui sort demain en
france et qui a connu un énorme succès
aux états unis
michel drucker a pu rencontrer l'acteur
qu'il recevra plus longuement
samedi dans champs elysées et nicole
cornu langlois nous parle de ses
prouesses deux frères raymond et charlie
c'est paris depuis l'enfance se
retrouvent et apprennent au cours d'un
voyage à communiquer à se connaître à
s'aimer et c'est difficile car l'un est
totalement égoïste et l'autre autistes
du tunindex qui n'existaient pas si je
suis raymond maintenant rien de tout
cela n'existe je ne vous vois pas je me
fiche de ce que vous pensez hors santé
je ne pense rien de vous vous êtes
transparent c'est ça raymond et pourtant
c'est une personne
ce qui est ironique c'est que charli
réapprend à 10 face à son frère raymond
qui est totti alors que charlie en fait
c'est un autiste du coeur
alors incapable d'altruisme ils se
rapprochent d'abord de son frère par
intérêt car c'est autistes savants à une
prodigieuse mémoire cette soif milliards
à fin du casting
chiquita cinq manches face à une
hémorragie
j'aimais beaucoup émue j'étais triste de
dire au revoir
c'était devenu un ami et baie comeau
faire c'est donc le charmeur
manipulateur qui fera le chemin vers son
frère enfermé à travers des situations
conventionnelle ou extravagante toujours
drôle pour faire passer le message
d'amour ou handicap c'est un mot rapide
de rugby c'est important puisqu'il
s'agit de la composition du quinze de
france pour la rencontre contre l'ecosse
au parc des princes samedi prochain
dominique erbani d'habitude troisième
ligne jouera pour la première fois en
deuxième ligne à la place de gilles
bourguignon béraud chant et art mari ont
été rappelés en remplacement de la faune
cécillon et 11 mars
rendez vous donc samedi après midi en
direct sur antenne 2 dames ou encore les
résultats du tiercé d'enghien
aujourd'hui à l'arrivée le 12 le 5 et le
9 5 francs dans l'ordre rapporte vaincu
1457 francs 50 et dans un ordre
différent 5691 francs 50
voilà c'est josé blanc lapierre qui vous
parlera du temps dès demain dans un
instant vers minuit dernier rendez vous
ce soir pour l'information avec philippe
lefait demain 6h 45 da sur roger zabel
et j'aurai le plaisir de vous retrouver
demain à 20 heures
très bonne soirée avec tout ça